[Musique]
rends-toi l'exclu tort oh oui je savais
que j'allais venir me chercher et j'ai
tout prévu superman mais je tiens
retrouvé malgré le fait que tu caches
dans un immeuble en plomb ça aussi gelé
prévu le ca l'immeuble aux cas qui ne
pouvait pas voir au travers était
forcément ma cachette
tu avais prévu du 2 juin avaient prévu
depuis avait prévu mais je ne pouvais
pas arrête de faire le perroquet fit
envoyer des mails jamais répondu à ça
aussi je l'avais prévu je savais qu'elle
est passé par sochaux bagdad a tué un
cerveau malade l'ex je vais t'emmener en
taule je m'échappe près comme d'habitude
alors je te rattraperait tu sais le
mieux c'est ça que tu restes avec moi tu
restes tout le temps avec moi parce que
je fais rien des bêtises quand t'es pas
là à l'écriture m'a emmené mois dans sa
forteresse de solitude on vivra tous les
deux je te ferai à manger de ménage je
comprends pas tu vois travers les murs
ça veut dire qu'ils voient à travers mes
vêtements tu aimes bien ce que tu vois
tu aimes bien je suis assez en acier
c'est mon asus est comme toi tu sais moi
je vois pas à travers les murs mais en
tout cas je peux voir que à travers tes
vêtements que tu es bien pâtit est-ce
que je peux t'appeler calais oh tu m as
kryptonite
[Musique]
bassal lex luthor qui est moi qui a pu
faire ça c'est permanent c'est pas du
tout c'est étrange on dirait qu'il a
explosé de l'intérieur ouais c'est
bizarre c'est comme c'est un marteau
piqueur l'avait vieux os
est-ce que ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est quoi cette matière verte et gluant
je sais pas c'est pas je vais y aller
moi c'est sylvain bondirait je suis seul
[Musique]
bon